hi Susan how are you great how are you
Morgan I'm doing great uh that first
episode was so addictive you left us on
the biggest Cliffhanger ever is this
what the audience gets to look forward
to each episode
yes I'd say the whole thing is edited to
make sure that you have a cliffhanger at
every episode definitely that's the one
thing we can guarantee you won't
understand what's going on in any
episode fully you'll have to coming back
that's what they're concerned about and
that's definitely happening and there
are a lot of Secrets and there are a lot
of twists and turns and there is a lot
of big hair and and
diamonds and music there's more and more
music as things go on and uh yeah that's
that I think you get a little taste but
it flies I think the first episode flies
by pretty fast so I think it kind of
gets has there's so much information to
get out in the first one the pilots are
always the hardest uh but I think that
you settle in even easier as time goes
on as episodes go on
I love that you know when you're playing
a character like Dottie the queen of
country music do you get used to the
hair like does that become part of the
character like you look forward to that
it's a necessary part of the character
yes Trace Adkins why he doesn't cut his
hair
he was our super model for that he you
know yeah I think the hair and the lace
and The Fringe and the boots and the
jewelry and of course the accent are uh
and the sense of humor and uh you know
are all necessary and uh I'm pretty
low-key low maintenance actually so it's
um a big part of what tempted me was
just going into that world uh that I
knew really nothing about I mean there's
certainly country songs that I liked I
loved the stories that country songs
tell I think the whole South is a hub of
kind of Storytelling
but I didn't
really ever think of what it was like to
have these dynasties you know at all
well if you're playing the queen of
country music who do you think in real
life is the queen of country music
well of course there was a great
similarity between The Judds you know
with uh her and the two girls because
our two girls end up uh both singing and
competing
uh I I again don't know that much I mean
I think there's been a lot of great
certainly Dolly Parton and thank you
very much for my vaccine but I think
Dolly Parton is very very special and is
definitely clean and she's still around
and still and has written some amazing
songs uh I guess you really to get the
true whoever is considered the true
Queen you'd have to ask people in
country music I don't think you know I'm
in a position to make that decision
how nice is it getting to work so
closely with Trace Adkins obviously a
huge part of the country music scene
because your Chemistry was so fantastic
it was my rock you know and I definitely
um I know people talk to him about me
and people talk to me about him because
we're from such opposite ends of every
Spectrum spectrum that you could imagine
and we found plenty to Common Ground And
he's a total kind you know took really
good care of me and
um uh professional
and you know when he smiles it's like
the sun comes out because he's like this
big serious huge guy I mean luckily I
have uh you know in my life uh people
that are six five I think he's even six
six or something so you really feel his
presence and he doesn't say much but
when he does it really lands you know
that yeah that deep resonance and I
really love him and I was very lucky to
get to go to the Country Music Awards
with him and that's when I really saw
how respected he was but then that
community and
um yeah so he was a big part of
helping me understand
also the difference between the country
music then and the more recent country
music which is very different according
to him so that was also a treat
that's awesome are we going to hear you
sing it all throughout the series
well
um a bit
um yeah I mean luckily not that much but
yeah I mean it's mostly the other guys
and it was a very
the the music directors were it's a very
specific thing so even these people who
really could sing yeah were
tested and trying to get uh the phrases
right and that feel you know it wasn't
just about singing and key and and tune
it was a
very very
um precise
uh difficult thing that was asked of
them and Anna you know and Beth thank
God Beth you know she's got a set of
pipes on her that's one of my most
moving and moments against me all the
time are the duet that they have in the
first uh episode I just love that yeah
it's so good
um you know there's so many amazing
cameos I was so impressed to see each
Shania Twain uh Martina McBride Tanya
Tucker is there anyone that you would
love to come see on the show
well I Dolly Parton I mean I I just
think she's really really smart and
humble and
has survived a long long time and her
whole story of where she came from and
everything I think that she's uh very
special and I haven't run into to her
yet I don't know if I ever will but I
love you Dolly oh okay we need to make
this happen we're putting this out in
the
universe
um I will watch you in anything I think
a lot of people can agree you're one of
my favorite actresses uh what was it
about this script and this character
that you thought yeah this is what I
want to tackle well I think a lot of the
things that you talked about I just
thought would be fun
um that's very important for me I I you
know I have enough oxed in my life and
with the world and everything else
without
you know being all stressed out when I'm
working so I want to have fun even when
things are difficult like that man
walking or Lorenzo's Oil there's still a
certain satisfaction from telling a
story that you believe in and so for me
working is not work and I just thought
this is a great
opportunity to get into a place that you
know nothing about I mean this is why
I'm not a dental hygienist if you get to
you know
experiment with all these different
places and people and you eventually
know that everybody wants and loves the
same things and and needs the same
things and are afraid of the same things
on some level and it's kind of
unenforced compassion and I knew nothing
about this bubble and um uh so I thought
yeah I'll jump let's do it